this podcast and every other podcast
that I make is supported by patreon
where patrons actually uh at Al
Charizard to here get every episode of
playwatch listen early and unedited plus
a bunch of other perks depending on the
tier so if you would like to support
check the link in the description or if
you are an audio listener go to
patreon.com hello everyone future Alana
here it's been a minute since I've done
one of these future Alana inserts I've
missed you
um before we get any further into this
episode I just wanted to add some
context to something that we spoke about
about halfway through the episode uh
timely of us which never happens we
discussed the cancellation of e3 which
at the time I said was rumored uh that
has now been confirmed E3 this year has
been canceled so just before we get into
that conversation I wanted to
just a dress that we recorded earlier in
the week before the news of the
cancellation which um the official
statements from readpop said you know
they were sorry that they had to cancel
and that they felt it was in the best
interest of representing the industry
correctly um uh if you're watching on
YouTube I'll leave a link in the
description but um essentially yeah just
wanted to let you all know that has in
fact happened we're talking about it in
a speculative way on the episode but I
feel like everything we say uh still
stands so here it is yes okay so my face
that's why I have yeah let's talk about
this a lot right here yeah so my boxing
match is uh April 15th the
creatorclash.com you can get tickets
we've spoken about it a few times
um but I'm just at a point now where I
either have like a split lip or like a
busted eye like I have right now I
literally just came from boxing like
walked up the staircase to do this
podcast I'm super sweaty I just got hit
in the face a lot
it's happening things are happening so
is it is that so here's my question that
given the context of these bruises I
feel comfortable asking is it an
interesting creative challenge learning
how to do makeup to kind of minimize
things like that is that in itself an
interesting kind of thing to go through
never tried I'm not wearing any makeup
right now oh you're not oh sorry okay
and I thought that
my I think makeup's really cool like I'm
very Pro makeup um I think I've spoke
about this with Austin on an episode
before I think makeup's really cool I
think it's a cool like form of
self-expression it's a whole art form
right I think it's rad I like watching
people do cool makeup I'm always
impressed when I speak to a makeup
artist
um
and it's not that I'm not interested or
I don't like it but I'm too lazy to
really do a lot of it like right it's
not laziness it feels like efficiency me
too yeah that's naturally beautiful what
do you need it for you know I can't yeah
this this it just happens I just got
this Natural Glow yeah it's amazing
maybe it's Maybelline no I think I just
um have trouble like prioritizing
hair and makeup like again two minutes
ago my hair was just above my head and
all I did was pull it down so it's all
sweaty and like it's stuck like this
because it's just wet you look like a
mess I feel like a mess the eye is it's
wild like I feel like people must see
Rahul and I walk around and be like
oh yeah and I'm like it's boxing I swear
I'm fine and it just keeps it just keeps
happening but no I am I I wish I could
be the kind of person who spends I don't
know 20 minutes every morning doing
makeup but I don't have it in me and I
envy those people I wish I could tap
into whatever that is I just don't but I
wish that's I'm sure there's an
interesting form to doing that like when
we have created Clash the Saturday night
is the fight
Sunday there's a Gala and I imagine
right we're all gonna be like massive
it's gonna look like the cover of like
uh Suicide Squad 100 would be like a
bunch of you looking it's incredibly
Glam but also massively so I messaged
some of the girls and I was like do you
guys want to get like a professional
makeup artist and give them the context
of this so that we can all like have
like bridal makeup done so we don't look
too bad uh so we're probably gonna do
that just so that we can hide
the face situation now the biggest
trouble I'm having with this eye is that
it's like a little bit swollen so like
I'm kind of having a bit of trouble
seeing which hasn't been fun but you
know what I did get to see today Mike
okay tell me I'm really proud of that
Segway which I haven't even segued yet I
did that's good I'm excited new gameplay
of The Legend of Zelda tears of the game
yeah this looks good did you watch it
looks good I did because I wanted to ask
you and I'm aware this is a rude
question
all of the things they're doing in terms
of like I just asked you about the
makeup you're not wearing bars so that's
a compliment
that's fair that's fair
um this is a rude question because I I
know it's not this simple and it varies
from Studio what we're seeing for
tears of the Kingdom in terms of like
and now you can combine these two
weapons and create a new weapon yeah
well now you can combine these three
items and put a fan on it and it makes a
raft how complicated is that like when
we're already but we're I'm already
thinking about how impressive the
physics were in breath of the wild and
now they've got weapons and vehicles
that you can combine seemingly based on
anything I feel like maybe some of the
Gaming Community might underestimate how
difficult that is to program because
there's all these accusations of it
looking like DLC which I guess is a
thing we now just say for sequels but
psychologist
I don't know how to phrase the question
how how do you make game where can
combine anything
so
the honest answer if you'll allow me to
indulge in it's yeah so the honest
answer is to get it on its feet not that
hard and this is something that
genuinely is one of the big Indie
benefits that people don't really know
about
is if you want to if you want to put
that together jaguely like you know make
like a Gary's Mod style kind of thing
where it's like yeah we plunk stuff
together and it just works and there's
lots of gameplay opportunities
very easy like you could make a
prototype of that there will be I'm sure
there'll be someone's one of the kind of
game developer YouTubers will absolutely
do this overnight like there is 100 you
could get a prototype on its feet where
you can kind of start putting things
together and they kind of work in this
way what's impressive is when you see
I'm sorry and Indies have this freedom
to do this because there's a certain
degree of expectation for Jank like it's
okay if something spins off into
infinity or something goes wrong right
what's impressive is when you see a
triple a studio especially one like
Nintendo who puts the the kind of
intuitive gameplay front and center that
kind of inviting gameplay front and
center
when they do it it's to me it's very
impressive and much harder because they
have to hit a quality bar because breath
of the Wild Way in excess of what you'd
expect right all the stuff we saw people
do with the physics where like people
will like activating bombs and flinging
themselves halfway across the map and
stuff
even though that didn't seem like it
should be possible I would not have
described any of it as janky
exactly that's the challenge whereas
there's definitely indie games that do
this like there's been indie games where
you can kind of put together your own
like machinery and physics and have fun
with it for like decades right like
there's definitely lots of games like
that the the thing with them though is
of course they are janky they are yeah
Gary's Mod for example can do all of
this stuff and was doing this stuff like
15 years ago but you wouldn't be able to
release it as a kind of and that's I've
seen people kind of criticizing the
the video Nintendo per hour because you
know things are clipping through the
floor things aren't looking quite as
smooth as they could yeah like that's it
to get it to that level is is where it's
only slightly janky is very impressive
um and that's the stuff that yeah that's
the stuff that stands out to me because
and also to be honest just like from a
design ethos point of view like uh you
know I have a good relationship with
Nintendo have lots of conversations with
them about designing about the stuff we
make and the the overwhelming kind of
aspect of their approach and their kind
of philosophy as a studio is yeah it's
it's this kind of it's It's designing a
classic kind of inviting sense it's the
it's a coffee mug you want to pick up
you know what I mean like it's really
consistently like bug-free like like
when you think about it please yeah yeah
when was the last time you saw like a
frame rate issue in the Nintendo okay
that actually did happen a lot okay but
yeah anything else like is so uncommon
yeah like this they are their design is
really old school in that it is not
about like so you know with like a game
we've made for example on most games
there's a certain amount of assumption
that like the player is going to meet us
halfway right like we know if you buy a
game as a player you're gonna give us
like quarter of an hour half an hour
before you get pissed off with us you're
gonna you're gonna buy in you're gonna
give us a chance to impress you and we
might have to make a tutorial we might
have to explain things to you and we're
gonna we're gonna there's gonna be a a
melding of Mines there and there's kind
of a give and take that is not the
Nintendo ethos of design Nintendo it
needs to be you want to joyfully pick it
up and play it like it's got that
immediacy to it so the idea of taking
that approach to design and doing stuff
like this which is really kind of
um creative and expressive that's really
hard to do because this can't go wrong
right this is a game that has to appeal
to an audience who've never experienced
these kind of mechanics before and
they're not going to forgive the game if
stuff goes weird or wrong so no it's
genuinely like the the
level I know they will be taking it to
in terms of the design of the experience
that's what's impressive and that's
what's really hard you're gonna like I
said you'll see YouTubers or YouTube
game developers 100 have made like the
fan and the raft bits and you can clonk
them together I mean that takes a data
prototype it's the layer on top of that
that makes it actually like work in the
whole lot of quality yeah so what is
that QA
like what is it I mean it makes it
partially
play testing design I mean to be fair a
lot of Nintendo's approach is just
really good design up front with lots of
really intuitive smart designers at the
front and then yeah play testing it
putting in front of people and then yeah
QA and all of the many bugs out of it
which will which isn't you know that's
the other thing it's like it's probably
massive for something like this like I
mean open world in general is crazy from
a QA perspective open world where the
player you know if you're testing
something you know this but I'm I'm
talking past you right like the the the
the uh but like QA for an open world
game like if you've got 10 guns in your
game the QA person will have to run
around the entire game world with every
single gun that's in your game shooting
at things and seeing if anything goes
wrong
if you if there's a specific kind of
armor you can be wearing they have to go
around with all of those guns and the
armor or not the armor so that doubles
the work because they have to kind of
accommodate that how all of the
combinations people could come up with
here you literally technically can't
it's impossible you couldn't test you
couldn't test it so it becomes a case of
how do you even test for that process
how do you check that it's it's funny
when you talk to designers who've worked
on like Mega games so like the No Man's
Sky Team for example like their QA
process they literally made drone like
virtual drones and sent them out and
they just the drones would like go and
take photographs of plants and then
someone would come in in the morning and
just click I don't know if they ever
said this publicly I might be saying
something they shouldn't be sorry did
you come in the morning and sorry sure
they like just come in in the morning
and just click through all of these
screenshots and see if anything janky
came up on screen because that was the
only way they could sort of test it but
even then you know you've got millions
it is my favorite thing to remind the
player base that I advocate probably too
much for I know it's a really small
chunk of people and certainly an even
smaller chunk of my audience of people
who say like game designers the lazy
game of the lazy how did they not catch
these bugs is that basically the first
two minutes that the game has been
released it has more play time than the
entire QA team put together could have
done in three years because the amount
of people you can get thousands of hours
just from the amount of people that are
able to play that first minute it's it's
impossible for a QA team to ever get the
amount of play time as the audience so
it's just impossible to find every bug
which yeah it seems so obvious in
retrospect like that's the thing with
any bug is once you know how to
reproduce a bug it's the most obvious
thing in the world and I've been on the
receiving end of that where we've made a
game put it through QA released it and
yeah like say like because of the number
of people playing oh this bug is
happening one percent of the time
[__] yeah you know and then you have to
deal with that get the patch done patch
takes time to do it has to go through a
process and there's a million bits of
bureaucracy between you and that patch
being a player so yeah it's it's it's an
experience my favorite free release book
that we had which I won't detail too
much because again I think this is
probably fine is um there was a thing
that accidentally increased atreus's
walk speed
so you could lose them in the level
because he was walking too much that was
a really big fan of that they're also
like all of these pre-release like I
don't know how many builds I would have
played like
10 I don't know a lot
um and I really miss all the times when
uh there were certain like bugs or
things that went implemented that I was
really fond of like the opening of
Ragnarok when uh none of the Wolves had
any animation so they were just sliding
and didn't have any facial expressions
like all of that stuff is like it's got
such a nice place in my heart and it no
longer exists because you have to like
delete all of them it's the notes as
well it's like the note from the
programmer going don't ever turn left if
you turn left or crash the gate yeah
these kind of archaic rules you have to
follow when playing and again I like it
makes me sad that they're gone and I
that's why I really appreciated that
week that we had where
um somebody tweeted a dumb tweet as they
do each week about uh saying Graphics
are the first thing done in the video
game where in retrospect that was
obviously because of course that's not
true but it did make all these Studios
release like really early builds of
games and it was such a fascinating
thing to see and I wish I wish we could
do more of that and also a credit to the
Indie space is a lot of time you can see
that whereas Triple A's still just so
secretive which is such a bummer uh it's
my favorite one of my favorite kind of
talks I've ever been to was I think it
was a dice Europe or something one year
the um creative director of um Horizon
just basically did a did a just showed
videos of basically like a time lapse of
like from the very first prototype with
like two Kill Zone guys running around
fighting a big lump of Cubes that was
that was the dinosaur that's awesome all
the way through like just showing like
10 builds or so of just kind of showing
that iteration showing you know the
character's hair get longer and then
shorter again and then longer again all
of that stuff like yeah just seeing that
a triple a scale is just so impressive
and interesting
um so yeah it's it's fine but I love it
I am
I have to can I say that I don't know if
I can say it really okay
yeah sorry for a reason I can't say I
had to look back at a bunch of early
stuff from Tron identity uh today and
just looking at like how the UI looked
you know six months ago and just going
oh that was an interesting choice why
did we get rid of that that looks cool
oh we got rid of that because it broke
this thing yeah it's all this
yeah it's so fast like seeing because
you forget because you're it's you know
it's like seeing a kid grow up like you
because you see it in such because
you're so close to it you don't see that
time lapse you don't see oh God
I wouldn't be allowed to like side by
side builds because I have to delete
them so
um yeah like it's like a security thing
we can't keep them when they're old so I
want that exhibition I want a museum to
like literally just walk me through
because you see occasionally there's a
brilliant one of um there's a good one
of Pinocchio the Netflix movie that came
out where they where they have all of
the kind of work in progress and they've
got a couple of stages set up with all
the lighting and stuff and it's the
stuff that you see and as the partner if
somebody works in stop motion I get to
see a lot of these sets it's just so
amazing seeing it behind the scenes but
then just yeah putting it in a museum
I'd love to have a museum exhibition of
something like a game of the scale of
Ragnarok where you can go through rooms
and be like this is the room that's
showing the pre-production process and
here's all the beautiful Concepts
here's the janky build I'm gonna pitch
this let's do this so that's a good idea
DM Corey now and be like hey Corey would
say yes
Corey would say yeah
and you see the audience really
interested whenever anything like that
does make it out
um yeah it's a real art to it there's
such an art to the game process and the
stuff that doesn't actually ever get
seen by the audience at the end of it
you're not great at sharing I love it I
wish we could share it more and I guess
directly related to this conversation
and to Zelda
where does physics actually start if
you're making a game like a big bag
depending on what your background is
yeah no but for a video game do you just
press the insert physics button like
literally how do you begin physics you
just click instant physics physics
I don't know I mean where it comes from
yeah
so um somebody has to make physics
someone has to make physics I mean the
only the straightforward answer is most
modern video game engines like physics
built in but where the craft of it is is
how you use that built-in stuff and also
rebuilding it
um yeah I don't think I've ever shipped
a game where we didn't have to rebuild
physics in some way because actually
it's one of those things it's like you
know cows look like horses in where you
should put is that Simpsons joke okay I
have no [__] idea
I think there's a joke in Simpsons where
there's like a film crew and they're and
they're uh painting no it's bunch of
they're painting a bunch of horses
it will be yeah and it's so someone says
that you can't use real cows in movies
you've got to use horses because cows
don't look like cows in movies there's a
certain degree of that like genuinely
with physics in games where you have to
you have to fake things things fall
slower for example Things Fall slower
than people think they do as a weird
thing when you're when you're uh if you
if you went up three stories and you
dropped a tennis ball it takes it longer
to hit the ground than the average
person would intuitively think it would
stuff like that where you kind of
there's a lot of like lies in video
games but also in videos if you are that
if you're playing as the tennis ball
maybe actually you want it to fall
slower so you so it feels more reactive
so you can make choices
so there's a whole layer of [__]
basically there's no such thing as just
plug in the realistic physics and you're
away it's always lies it's always kind
of you're always having to like make
stuff up
um but then yeah it's basically just
it's basically just maths it's just
force applied to objects and then
colliders on those objects that's most
physics from a like a video game point
of view
um force and collision and both those
things are very very hard to do it makes
it sound like it's didn't and I know
that it's not because I know the physics
evolves
like when you say it's just math math
seems like a constant that never changes
but I know that's not the case in video
games well what's what's really changed
this Fidelity right is is is the detail
of the simulation so if you think back
to like Half-Life 2 for example you know
there's a lot of crates a lot of Cubes
right very simple shapes
um a lot the easiest thing in the world
from uh physics point of view to do
mathematically is a sphere so you see
pool balls you know very early physics
in games was like snooker tables and
stuff
um uh monkey ball right that kind of
like those early games spheres are just
very easy mathematically because you
just need to know the point of the
center and the diameter circumference
diameter radius I was too confused yeah
you always see as long as you know those
things you can do it clearly yeah
because two spheres hitting each other
it's it's just a point it's anyway it's
simple mounts yeah
um but my point is
um that's very early then you get to
cubes in Half-Life 2 and now you get two
things where you can have like complex
mesh colliders or you can have
collisions that change shape over time
so if you've got a character moving
historically it would always be a
capsule so it'd be like a big cylinder
that represented that character I think
a lot of people will seem like in behind
the scenes of games like this weird kind
of wireframe cylinder around the
character that's a phys that's the the
simplest kind of way of representing a
character in physics now you see you
know people actually simulating the
physics of the object of the body and
stuff like that so it's Fidelity it's
the maths hasn't really changed it's
just how much maths you can do so how
many sums you can be doing how many
things you can have colliding with each
other
um also faking it as well because it's
video games so a lot of really complex
physics so if you're in a game and you
see like a massive complex structure
collapse often that'll be like pre-baked
so that would have been a complex
physics simulation that was done offline
rendered and saved and all of that data
about how things would move is then just
basically being played back to you stuff
like that I think something that I've
found
um
faking stuff that how long have I been
doing this for three years now the thing
that I found
difficult to hear like on YouTube videos
or whatever where people talk about like
dumb decisions in game design
and it's actually usually like the one
that I watched recently was from an
outlet that I really like I have friends
who work there I like them but I was
like you don't understand and I think
it's a really interesting one I didn't
even really talk about that I probably
wouldn't talk about outside of this
podcast on a regular YouTube video
people would just get really mad but
they understand if you're watching this
this is what you sign up for is um
people talking about dumb game design
decisions
because
they're like this logic doesn't make any
sense why would this door be here if you
can't open it and so many that's a
really bad example but so so many of
those things my response is it's there
because you don't actually care about it
like it's there because player
satisfaction tells me that even though
you can say this is a logical this thing
that doesn't make any sense why would I
go to this vendor for this because
that's more satisfying to you as a
player but it's a thing that I never
thought about before working in Game Dev
that I think about now all the time it's
like you can say something is illogical
or something is false or be like all
those physics don't make any sense but
sure they may not make sense but if they
did make sense you'd find it really
[__] boring and it's it's a really
weird thing to have adjusted to to be
like sure you can make a million videos
about that not making sense but I
promise if you take it one step further
and think about if it did make perfect
sense you would fight it dull boring it
wouldn't Propel you forward it wouldn't
be motivating enough like I think we had
a conversation previously about um The
Telltale decision making and how the
decisions don't actually really lead
anywhere and it's not players don't
actually really care that much about
choice they care about thinking their
choices have impact because for
expressing themselves yeah that's a
great way of putting it they care about
having the expression or having input
but they don't actually care that much
about
the choices being that different unless
they do care about choices on April 11th
they should play Tron identity though
don't we agree are we allowed to talk
about those choices I was going to ask
about that because I know you've you've
done a little bit uh more press for it
now can we talk about Tron identities I
wasn't fully segwaying we absolutely can
segue you're on a really interesting
subject there all I was going to say on
that was I remember hearing a really
great writer talking once I can't
remember who it was but they were
talking about plot holes it might have
been a long appears they're talking
about plot holes and their basic
contention was the
plot holes will always exist you can't
avoid plot holes good writers just make
it that you don't give a [__] about them
it's interesting you're you're paying
attention to other things I think we
have unfortunately there's a there is a
stream your answers in your question the
statement you said because you said well
you can make a million videos about
nitpicks it's like yes you can and they
are and that's and they will it's very
easy content yeah so I think we
unfortunately that kind of content has
become a bit too popular and a bit too
rewarding
everything's got flaws totally and so
that's interesting it's just again I
think so much of it is um like just take
it a step further and and the thought is
straight up if that were changed and if
they had done it in the realistic way
that you suggested you'd be bored you
wouldn't find it compelling there would
be nothing to propel you forward you
would lose momentum in this part of the
game like almost all of them in the most
recent that video that I watched there
was a list from again an outlet that I
like with people I like they weren't
doing it in like a hateful rage bait way
I wouldn't watch that kind of country
um but I had to turn it off because I
was like oh it's so obvious why this
happens but when it's not from this
perspective that I now have after three
years I can't even imagine what it's
like for someone who's been doing this
way longer uh it's not a perspective I
ever had before things have to be faked
for player satisfaction a lot of the
time and you have to like like for every
conversation we have about lunar
narrative dissonance with Nathan Drake
you know shooting a thousand people
while pretending to be a nice guy there
are probably a thousand videos about
that I'm sure I made comments about that
again before getting into Dev it's
because it doesn't matter you want to
shoot the stuff it's really fun it's
really fun so it's it's not there
because they're stupid and they didn't
think about the disconnect between
Nathan Drake being a mass murderer and
Nathan Drake having nice conversations
with Sully it's because it's fun it's
because you need something to do you
need the drama to propel you forward you
need that action combat to exist in that
game and what and what did they do next
after making that game that was heavily
criticized for that they made last of us
which was which is entire point of the
story of that game is a dissection of
what that violence does to someone true
and it's really interesting seeing
people who've not played the game talk
about the TV show being like Joel turns
out to be a bit of a dick in you know as
the thing goes on doesn't he it's like
yeah because in the video game he's
killed thousands of people by that point
because of me yeah um but anyway let's
talk about Tron identity yeah I like I
like that segue that's a good segue so
physics information identity
um there's zero physics and Trauma
density we've got no we got a couple of
waterfalls but that's fake physics
that's not real there you go fake
physics waterfalls you heard it here
first Gamers there's a YouTube video
Tron identity confirms awful fakes
physics yeah
um yeah I know that you you did some
press recent
recently we did we went to Disney World
so it inspired me to I was really cool
it's really cool especially as like a
proper Disney World yeah to go and like
go and see the park I got to go into the
because they're doing this Tron light
cycle ride which is lots of fun and I
got to go in with no one else there like
basically just and like as it is the
dream I just been walking walking
through like all the queuing areas and
like for a Disney nerd just to take my
time just walking through the space with
no one else there it was amazingly weird
and cool
um yeah what was the what was the event
was it where you give people hands on
um no I just did a bunch of in cheese I
did I think there's eight interviews
back to back that was fun that was
tiring
um but yeah no just kind of basically
like honestly just kind of gate crashing
a cool event about Tron and and talking
about my silly games what are you
allowed to tell us now what is it Mike
what is Trump's identity because I don't
I think we've alluded to it previously
but you were still pretty tight-lipped
yeah because I think the last time we
talked about it would have been when we
did the revealed teaser release so um
yeah so it's it's honestly if people
played like subsurface circular or
quarantine circular it's kind of what if
that but Tron and we had like the
resources to go and make something
really interesting with it and I think
that's where we basically have gone what
if they haven't played those games
um so so sub service circular and
quarantine circular with like two
basically text Adventure Games we made
but uh uh you generally like they're
quite quick to make and we made them in
gaps so we made subsurface circular
um while we were pitching for uh John
Wick and then
um because there was then a massive
contract negotiation as there often is
with licensed stuff we then did
quarantine circular as well then so we
made the two back-to-back kind of text
Adventure Games but they are basically
kind of dialogue driven Choice driven
Story game so you're in in both of them
you're playing as a character and
talking to a bunch of people making
decisions kind of investigating a world
doing lots of World building stuff
um and we basically yeah we um when we
started talking to Disney about Tron
um we kind of pitched them on this we
want to kind of create this Tron in Game
World we can tell game stories in and
kind of do cool stuff with and we were
talking about like what's the how do we
introduce people to that world and we're
like well we've done this twice and both
of those games half the same reviews are
this is awesome but I want to see more
events like that's the that's a good way
into these worlds so Nick in kind of uh
the classic kind of sci-fi Trope of a
detective going into a space and asking
questions because that lets you have the
player go and find out what the world is
and how that works yeah we're already a
big Tron fan before this deal came
together right
what's the approach though of like
getting into this particular kind of Ip
like I'm always curious anytime I talk
to any writer on any IP that isn't a
video game already like how much
research do you have to do
um so obviously you go back to the
source like so there was a lot of
research back into the original movie
there are books I've got most of them
behind Comics as well I think all books
as Comics there's a couple of games as
well so there's like an established law
which is basically uh there's a couple
of movies a video game
um a couple Comics like say a great TV
show Uprising that everyone should watch
which was oh I didn't know that was a
thing um
oh it was really good it was like a 20.
it was a car it was an animated show it
was it was back on like Disney XD came
out around the same time as Legacy which
was the more recent one yeah but it's
like Elijah Woods uh as this as this
character he's kind of Bridging the Gap
between the two movies and genuinely
like really ahead of its time like
genuinely really good kind of
interesting dramatic storytelling
um so yeah so so you go back you look at
all of that for me as then it's about
finding the threads so going okay well
what's interesting to me about this okay
trusting but whatever I'm finding
interesting there's probably other
people I can convince them that aspect
is interesting so just and it's spoilers
so I'm going to it but there's like two
or three threads that are kind of
introduced in like the original movie
and in Legacy that I was like these are
the things I would love to tell a story
like a Sci-Fi story around so those are
the things that we kind of build on
um I think we've done a pretty good job
I think it's like
good I don't know you never know before
it releases but like I think the stories
I think it's a really I think we found
an interesting story there
tron's a really great world and very
interesting kind of Mythology and
there's just a lot of space to tell
interesting stories how much back and
forth do you have to do with Disney
to make sure that that IP is being
handled correctly it's like it's super
collaborative like a lot of check-ins
very collaborative yeah lots of
conversations so yeah it was um so
basically yeah once every couple of
weeks
um I do a call in with Disney and it's
essentially like just almost a whole
like a whole Dev team basically on their
side of like people who are so you've
got like my producer Heidi um who I did
a bunch of press with
um but then you've also got like a
writer an artist uh a sound guy a game
design like just basically a mirror of
essentially like what a Dev team's
makeup is
um and their primary role is with with
our games but also with other people's
stuff to just kind of be the voice of
Disney and kind of play with that with
us
um and it's crazy like you know Disney
employed writers yeah artists oh that's
interesting so they kind of with and
it's really cool
departments but on the Disney side not
working on the game
Consulting on them I mean they're
working with us on the game but yeah
they're not like they're not internally
so for example yeah so for example but
they're not so so for example um there's
a great writer over there and he he uh
works with a bunch of the different
projects that are currently in
production
um of which our stuff is some of it
um and he's he's uh he's writing stuff
he's he's writing for the parks he's
writing stuff for Disney across the
board like he's doing different various
different writing things and Disney he
wrote the um he wrote the queue for the
new guards as a Galaxy ride so as I was
on the Queue I was like hearing lines
from Chris Pratt I was like that sounds
like a line heater right that's that's
what it is
um and but that guy can give me feedback
and what's brilliant is he can give me
feedback that's like oh well when we
were doing the Indiana Jones ride we had
to solve this problem in this way
because we knew player we knew the
people on the ride weren't going to look
at that thing they want to look at this
thing so we had to kind of do the story
into so he'll have all of this kind of
weird insight into like the Disney way
of doing this uh and then he kind of
bounces that off me and then in return
you know I will you know I walk him
through what we're trying to do and it's
kind of a really nice back and forth
it's really cool that happens across all
the Departments it's really like it's
it's genuinely it's like um it's like
going to school it's fantastic it's such
an amazing opportunity to learn from
them
um so I do that every couple of weeks
and I'll I'll update them on where we
are with things and we'll kind of Bounce
stuff over and obviously you know
there's there's Milestones where which
are a big chunk of stuff to go over with
them but but generally it's just kind of
a back and forth hey here's a thing
we're thinking about and then also on
top of that like all of the the
franchise people and the people
elsewhere within Disney who are focused
on Tron stuff so there's just a really
cool back and forths across the world
and I'll go over to La once every
on this one it's close it's about once
every kind of three or four months on
John Wick I was going over like once
every two months to to me with the with
the film people on on John Wick but um
but yeah with this one it's it's a
really nice back and forth yeah um and
then and then that's that is to answer
your original question that's kind of
how they check in on how we're doing
with the IP but what's really cool is
obviously everyone just wants to make a
really cool Tron story so it's kind of
it's all it's all pulling in good
directions do you add Bissell games have
apartment heads as well like do you have
a head of Art
um we're we're 20 people so we don't
have that for every department so like
we have there's like an art lead for
example uh there's Prodigy management
there's but but yeah we don't have it's
not like it won't be like a triple A
team where you've got like every single
track has its its leads its managers
um but yeah so we have yeah we have some
the the basically if it's a bigger group
of people so for example like our art
department is quite big so that's got
its own lead because it would just be
impossible amount of work for me to kind
of coordinate all of that sorry Benders
amazing yes he's just brought me his uh
Stingray it's very important that I it's
very good acknowledge history oh but I
guess does the stingray have a little
face on the board it has like a cute
little face was really bad at hatching
but we've been trying to hey Benji catch
because he sucks at it he's terrible
um the reason that I asked about sorry
the the art Department specifically is
because like when you're having this
these meetings with Disney is your art
lead talking to their art person
uh generally goes through me okay
because I I technically am the art
director on our games because we're
small enough for like creative art
direction is through me that makes sense
um but but we do pull people in like if
there's something if there's a specific
kind of uh Department that needs to have
that direct connection we will
um but no generally it's going through
it's all going through me it's one of my
jobs um because I know obviously you
worked with Austin on uh John Wick hex
um for things like like a sound
Department how much of that do you
Outsource I guess art that applies to as
well how how much of it are you
Outsourcing or versus what's being done
sounds one of the few things yeah sounds
one of the few things we still fully
Outsource um so we will work with um
sword identity there's a composer I
don't think we've announced who's doing
that so I'll stop but the composer and
the sound designer so you've got two
people basically externally who
essentially are contractors like music's
a lot more complicated contractually
which I've been trying to show before
but yeah yeah so there's a so those are
those are external contracts everything
else we're doing internally
um but like I'm John Wick for example we
had like our animation was done
externally so there's this is the first
time we're pulling a lot of stuff
in-house with with identity how many
people do you have now I know you said
20 on this game but is your whole studio
20 people
it's sorry the Studio's 20 people I
don't see it was a bit less than that
but it's been very interesting like even
over the however many years we've been
doing this show Too Many now three I
think it's it's been feels like so it
feels like a seven or eight I feel like
fifthal games has grown a ton and yeah
you've done like two big IP releases in
in even that span of time is this
something that like you intend to
continue as part of the ethos of the
studio or is it just the opportunities
that have been afforded to you
it's I mean it's probably more the
latter just it's been interesting stuff
that's come our way
um and for me it's a really good because
definitely like this is a wanky thing
that everyone says but it's genuinely
true like a big part of this job for me
is learning so anywhere where I can put
myself in a room with kind of clever
people who I wouldn't normally get to
talk to so like you know getting to talk
about combat systems which adds to
helski like Jesus Christ like that's
worth doing right like that's an
experience and similarly with with
Disney stuff like that's you know that's
that's open that door so that's what I
like about it is it just gets me in a
room with people who maybe haven't even
with Disney they're they're much more um
they're much more games focused so I'm
generally talking to people who've
worked on games but even then there's
you'll you'll meet people who've maybe
never thought about games before but
have a really interesting perspective
that we can kind of pull in
um so I love that now
and they've got some very clever kind of
very experienced games people in that
department
um but the but like it's just it's a
really
um so so that for me that's the main
draw is just like getting to be in the
room with a really interesting creative
people
um so I I think if if we keep getting
offered interesting stuff John Wick
definitely opened a bunch of doors in
terms of like people can see oh you
didn't [__] that up yeah exactly
um and then uh and then hopefully you
know people like Tron as well so
hopefully we'll get to keep playing but
so far so good and Disney have been
fantastic like genuinely really cool to
work with yeah another very easy segue
speaking of John mckext
um that just happens to be relevant this
week just lighting them up
um yeah the last time that I would have
had a press interaction with you is when
I was invited to go see John Wick X at
E3
um and you didn't show up is that right
I did tell you okay to be fair but I
couldn't make it
um but how much of a big deal like we
spoke about dice recently we've
obviously spoken about GDC about how
important these conventions are two devs
and how much networking happens there
that like games literally get funded at
Dice and GDC how much of a blow do you
think it'll be to Debs if the rumors if
you haven't seen them uh that E3 is
going to be canceled this year and thus
probably I've never seen that it just
it's kind of started to come out in that
like uh Ubisoft
um announced they were doing something
and then they just pulled out even
though they had already announced it and
and now there are concerns that
um maybe the scale is too small for them
to justify I don't imagine E3 is
actually going to be 100 canceled but I
know it's now um I think it's read pop
now that's doing it who does comic con
um but yeah my question there is like a
consumer event yes my
the way I view E3 is that I think E3 is
extremely helpful
for press even for Content creators for
people to have the opportunity on those
ends like it's very very helpful like my
first E3 I was working for BBC but it
was a great way for me to meet a ton of
people community managers PR people to
get more access to games it was very
helpful for the journalism side of my
career and I don't know what I would
have done without it much more helpful
than even something like a Pax the GDC
is not really useful to press
um dice I don't even you can't even get
in in a lot of cases
um so I definitely think it'll be a lot
harder for for journalists and content
creators but do you feel like that
people on the dev side of the industry
will lose a lot if E3 no longer goes
ahead
um I I mean I think to an extent like
something always Rises if there's a need
something will rise it's definitely it's
definitely a dent Jeff Keeley will save
us Jeff Keely will rise
I I definitely
I there's it's definitely a hit like
it's honestly it's similar to what
you're saying with the Press side like
especially in the smaller developer side
like I can't get IGN to come to the UK
to meet with us and look at our game I
can't I don't have that power
um but I can go to E3 and I can say hey
we're at a place where you also are can
I have an hour of your time to come and
kind of show you some stuff yeah and
that's the big that's the big win is all
of those people in the same place all of
them looking for Content all of them
wanting to share that's cool ditto on
the executives you know
um so it's it's there's definitely
there's definitely benefits to anything
that brings a bunch of those people
together
whether or not it needs to be E3 shaped
I guess that's that that we'll see but
the sort of the same there's definitely
you miss out on the Press it's those
relationships that that probably get
hurt more from E3
yeah that's the that's the that's the
that's the thing we would feel is you
know we and and it becomes it just
becomes the case if you have to find
other ways to to talk about stuff
because obviously all the big Publishers
and the big platforms and all this stuff
they're fine because they can they they
can throw their owners
I'm not concerned I think we will be
fine without those but actually you also
potentially better because they can
control the message control the pacing
of that message the timing of that
message
um how that message gets out who that
message gets out to the kind of they can
own a day you know if if you're doing
the big the big PlayStation event you
can you can own that day with the press
and you know you'll get coverage so from
from my scale it becomes a case of well
are there opportunities for us to latch
on essentially so doing things like you
know we did the Nintendo director
recently before that we were a d23 with
Disney you know similar things like you
know platforms or publisher-owned kind
of Alternatives events
and and but that but that still requires
that requires you know us to have
relationships with those companies right
and us to have those kind of and if
you're a new developer who maybe hasn't
built up you know the ability to call up
Nintendo and say hey we've got a cool
thing to show that's you know that's a
lot of steps involved in getting to that
point then having less events makes that
harder and those events being more
expensive being very american-centric
that's definitely something I've
experienced like I can go to my first
GDC until I made my first successful
game because I couldn't have afforded it
before did you happen to see yeah
there's Josh Sawyer's acceptance speech
at the GDC Awards I didn't know Josh
Sawyer uh I'm a big fan he's the um
director of Fallout New Vegas but also
pentiment and they've won I don't
remember exactly the phrasing at the
Game of Thrones Choice Awards it's
either best narrative or best story or
I think best narrative is what they call
it
and he basically
um I think made a great point when
accepting the award about how GDC is not
particularly accessible
um and I mean tickets thousands of
dollars
um The Vault is extremely expensive
which is how you find all of the the
talks and I I've read tons of books
about game design and I still feel like
I've I don't know the 20 30 however many
I've read none of them have ever been as
useful to me as some of those GDC Vault
talks um and those are shorter there are
like two or three that I just sent to
every designer who I work with now just
because it's such a shorthand for just
like you need to know that everything in
this one hour of totally and it's also
the GDC Vault talks which for anyone
who's unaware are basically just like
um game devs giving presentations on
games that have just come out there are
actually several forgotten for Ragnarok
uh which is really cool a lot of our
team went and did different talks
um but they're very focused towards
developers and that kind of content
doesn't really exist that broadly
anywhere else um and they all get put in
What's called the GDC bolt which is just
the recordings afterwards essentially
and yeah some of those are which is the
best cheat mode for developers like it's
amazing I can watch uh I know I I just
yeah I can't say what I've been watching
because it reveals what we're watching
up next but like I've been able to watch
like stuff about AAA games that came out
like five years ago or so and I'm just
nicking their approaches because these
guys like they're such a great
experience of sharing but it's I think
this is I think this would be hard for
like the average person who's not pay
who's not seen these things to kind of
understand but like literally if you
want to know here's what I watched for
fun that didn't inform anything I'm
working on the Spider-Man guys literally
did like an hour-long presentation on
how they calculate the swing I've seen
it the Rope exactly right and they're
not leaving anything out if I wanted to
go and make a Spider-Man game or you
know off brand Spider-Man game I suppose
I could go and just Implement exactly
what they've described and it would take
me literally months less than it took
them you know we talked about this on
the show before like being first is the
hard thing being second and watching a
GDC talk on how someone else solved all
those problems and kind of building on
their shoulders that's how games get
better at the pace that they get better
because we're not having to constantly
reinvent stuff I can look back at
basically any Triple A game from the
last 20 years and go how did they do
that and watch the talk on it well the
the example I always use and if you're
not seeing this one you should see this
one which I think it's called reading
the player's Mind through his thumbs
which is bad name for a talk but it's
it's from the it's from the uh the
infamous team and it's literally
basically how how we take thumbstick
data and make it feel like you're
actually controlling the play the
character doing cool stuff and you don't
just keep falling off of things and it's
basically about how to Intuit and
understand the thumbstick input that
video is the reason our games feel good
because I watched that five years ago
and just it blew my mind and again like
that stuff that r d costs hundreds of
thousands of dollars to get to those
conclusions and I just got it for I
think again I think I got it for like a
30 quid
accessible and that's part of the
problem is like the vault is a nice
issue not only incredible in terms of
the amount of information that you get
but
um I also find it really inspiring even
if like you said I watch you talk about
something that I will never work on I
don't have I I one of my favorites is
talking about how Platinum figures out
the amount of milliseconds between
pressing a button and the combat
animation completing to make sure that
it's satisfying to a player I loved list
listening to that because it's just like
it's so inspiring in terms of the
industry that you work in and like
staying super passionate and just being
like holy [__] this is so cool even if
it's something I'll never touch but
basically Josh's point was like we can
talk about that openly and and talk
about how great it is but I think it's
still hundreds of dollars at this point
to get access I think it is now yeah
back then there was an audio only pass
that was like 50 free and that doesn't
exist anymore as far as that's how I
listen to that it's not getting to San
Francisco which is obviously notoriously
expensive and then there are people from
the hotels are insanely expensive during
that week having to get visas and having
to get access so
um major props to Josh for bringing that
up when accepting an award from GDC
effectively always always fight the hand
that feeds you that's the first room
um
but yeah no it's it's it isn't it is an
issue and and that's one thing that
online events obviously cut out a lot of
that stuff but it's it's you know it
isn't the same as physically meeting
people I I definitely I think what we
need of on it need honestly is more
small events locally I think that's the
thing yeah that's the thing I think as
an industry we're rubbish at is we kind
of offload all of this stuff to San
Francisco and and to be fair GDC have
been pretty
um what's the word for this uh
constricting in terms of like if you do
a talk at GDC you're not allowed to do
it elsewhere you know you're not they
actually they want to own that
exactly and like I've had it before
where like I've done a talk at GDC that
was popular and I'm like oh I want to
use I'll use this at a future event and
then you read the small print and go oh
no I'm not actually allowed to and I
still have in those situations because
I'm a jerk but like it's it's like it's
a there's a there is a there is a
limiter there and we can we can support
local communities and local spaces and
kind of and and
that can work really well and there's
certain places in the world
um where something like GDC is very
inaccessible where they've they've built
their really their own really cool kind
of culture of uh of these events they've
made their own gdcs there's not GDC is
like the name of three or four events
wait actually really no way
it's really good about that I I hosted
their reveal of Adams talking to
developers from all over the world about
like their Game Dev communities and I
think the the team in Mexico that I
spoke to was especially really inspiring
they were like we can't go to America
here's what we've done come visit like
it was just so welcoming and so cool in
a way that I think GDC does a lot of
good and I think GDC like being on the
show floor there uh is super exciting
and uh I hosted GDC last year and it was
an honor and it was it felt amazing to
be there but I do also think they have
an accessibility problem where the
global market is concerned especially
because because the vault is so good and
that's
statue of limitations like just
literally just go okay we're gonna lock
down things for three years in the vault
so if you're a professional and you need
access to the newest stuff you can pay
fair enough but the amount of good they
could do just by opening that stuff up
and also frankly it's an amazing advert
because you watch a few of those videos
and they do put some stuff off on
YouTube but they should go further you
watch some of those talks and you want
to go to GDC because you're like [__] I
can just sit in a room for three days
watching lectures like this this is
amazing
um
I guess but I don't know they must they
must make a lot of money
sure I think well I think one thing that
definitely gec and this has been GC has
been guilty of this since I've been
going is gec was very much built I mean
it started as literally about 20 devs in
the living room there was like a little
a little Homespun Event in San Francisco
and obviously grew very quickly
but it was always targeted at business
use so it was always kind of American
game studios would send over you know a
bunch of their people to go and attend
it so it was kind of business
PlayStation have free access to the
vault as employees
exactly so and and Playstation
presumably spends a lot of money on that
so the main customers for GDC were big
games companies and and the pricing kind
of reflects that and I think that
doesn't necessarily fit the shape of the
games industry as it currently stands
like there's a lot more there's a lot
more Me's in the games industry than
there was 10 years ago so I think I
think having uh having that stuff open
up and frankly I'm in a very privileged
position now where my company's doing
well so I can afford to go to gec and I
can take some of my staff there and
stuff like that but like there's
definitely lots of Indies who are not in
that position and honestly it could just
be it could be looser and I think I
think you wouldn't lose much I think you
gain a lot
um because the other thing is there's a
lot of business now relies on there if
you're not a GDC pitching then you are
missing out on an amazing stuff we had
um we've we've we've had people we've
had we've been demoing our games do you
see for a long time and we've had really
good deals and stuff come out of that
and relationships and and
it would be cool if I was more open to
other people the one thing I will say on
that subject is you can do that stuff
without having GDC pass which is quite
nice
right you just have to be with your
email you travel you're still paying for
a hotel the John Wick X thing
which is I guess the same thing that's
why you that's why you refuse to come
you're like I'm not leaving I have to
walk 10 minutes
no I'm saying where the news is
yeah I refuse yeah it's it's uh it's
definitely a bummer and I think the the
E3 situation again I feel like I think
it would be a lot harder to break in um
as a journalist because I felt like that
was really important to me and I think
also with Twitter uh changing a lot I
it's really hard for me to give advice
on people who want to get into games
media now because the way that I did it
is now very different and I think that
sucks like I'm I that morally feels
shitty that I don't feel like the advice
that that like my advice was go to
events and meet people a lot and now I
think that's a little bit harder to do
without a thing like E3 to an extent
that's inevitability right like yeah as
you as you get older and more
experienced you all like like I get
asked by news for advice a lot and my
honest answer is I don't nothing that I
experienced 10 years ago is relevant to
your experience and that's just
it is it kind of is just it's it's I
guess it's progress
something about Tick Tock probably
probably do something on Tick Tock
that's probably what it is right that's
the advice all right tick tock I don't
know yeah whatever
do one of those Instagram stories
I heard it here first ladies and
gentlemen um all right I have to run to
a meeting business uh we've got your
business right now no you do not
um Austin was going to join us but I'm
guessing he got caught up and Troy is
unavailable right now but I'm a lot of
peace I'm a video game right now that is
Mike Bethel he is a video game director
and wishlist
[Music]
April 11th and 12th in some territories
apparently cool time zones how do they
work
I don't know